هذا موجز الاخبار ياتيكم من قناه الجزيره
اهلا بكم اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمدينه
كي اف ان قوات الدفاع الجوي قد اسقطت
مسيره ملغمه في احدث هجوم روسيه على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه واضافتنا حطام احدى
الطائرات الحق اضرار بمبنيين اداريين في
حي العاصمه
الاخباريه عن مصادر بان هناك ضغوطا غربي
قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان واشنطن تضعوا
لمسات الاخيره على خطط لتزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ باتريوت للدفاع الجوي وفي موسكو
قال
مسؤولونبلن ان منظومه ستصبح هدفا مشروعا
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في حال تسليمها
الى كيف
نقلت صحيفه بوليتكو عن برقيه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان اداره ايضا تواجه صعوبات في
تتبعين مال المساعدات الماليه والعسكريه
التي تقدمه
الى كل التقنيات المتاحه لتتبعه مليارات
الدولارات المقدمه للموكانيين بحسب
الصحيفه
قال رئيس حركه حماس يحيى السنوارنا الحركه
تمهل الجانب الاسرائيلي وقتا محدودا
لاتمام الصفقه تبادل الاسرى والا فاستغلق
ملف اسرى الاحتلال وتجد سبلا اخرى لتحرير
الاسرى الفلسطينيين على حد تعبيره
هذا هو عرضت وحده الظل تابعه لكتائب
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس عرضت
السلاح الجندي الاسرائيلي هدار جولدن
الاسير لدى القسام منذ عام 2014
لتاسيسه الحركه ان السلاح غنيمه من غنائم
عمليه اسر الظابط الاسرائيلي
في شريط الى الاتفاق الايطاليه الذي وقع
في الخامس من الشهر الجاري في السودان قال
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهاني
انه لا تسويه سياسيه هناك بالمعنى الذي
فهمه البعض وشدد على ضروره لا تحاول اي
جهه اختطاف لاتفاقي لمصلحتها كما اكد ان
القوه المسلحه لن تقر ايه اتفاق نهائيا
ينال من ثوابت
يه وممثل الاتحاد الافريقي بالسودان محمد
بلعيش ان بعض الاطراف في السودان تهدد
باسقاط الحكومه القادمه قبل تشكيلها مما
سماه الاقصى سياسي
اعلنها الرئيس الامريكي خلال منتدى
الاعمال ضمن القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
الاولى من نوعها في عهده بواشنطن عن صفقات
واستثمارات امريكيه جديده في افريقيا
تعزيز للشراكه وسيعرض بيضا دعما امريكيا
لزياده دوري الاتحاد الافريقي يشمل تخصيصه
تمثيل دائما له في مجموعه دول العشريه